For me these hard problems to be able to approach
them with the intention of alleviating suffering
in a large patient population, and globally
– the opportunity to create accessible,
safe and efficacious products to go after
and train, to unlock the body’s immune system
and actually solve these problems ourselves
is amazing.
So by turning the body into the drug factory
(because it’s naturally producing these
endobodies), I think that’s a revolution
in terms of the way we’re going to approach
chronic illness.
And so I’m pretty excited about that part.
So these are all vaccine based approaches.
What I like about vaccines is that if we can
turn your body on to activate against something
that is an agent of pain that your body itself
is generating, then you can have a very easy
way to take the product – it’s a single
shot once a year, potentially.
So you have a great compliance rate with your
patients, so it’s easy on your patient.
The cost is absolutely affordable and attainable.
So the cost becomes something that is accessible.
And you are in effect having a long duration
of that treatment.
That’s going to give us the best chances
to, in my opinion anyway, it’s going to
be one of the approaches that maximize our
chances against the opioids and against the
epidemic that’s outstanding.
In addition to that we have some other things
in our pipeline that are focused on the absorption
of opioids or the replacement of opioids from
a pleasure perspective.
That’s earlier and so not really worth incorporating
into what we’re doing here, but it would
be in like soon.
Those first two are big.
So, for example, we have an IL-6 vaccine that
I’m really excited about.
And there are indications surrounding sciatica
there that are really compelling.
And I think that that’s a huge need in terms
of being able to remove that suffering and
that pain in a long-acting, affordable, and
accessible way.
So that’s an example.
Another one is, there’s been a lot of noise
around CGRP and monoclonal antibodies that
have been improved around that for migraine.
And we’ve got a vaccine for CGRP that we’re
extremely excited about, and if you think
about the benefits of that it means that—one
of the big problems with getting people to
take drugs is when they feel better they don’t
want to take them.
But if your body is fighting that same target
then you don’t have that same compliance
issue.
And so you actually make it easier for the
patients to take the products that they’re
supposed to take in a timely manner and then
maintain the benefits of those products.
So I think that’s going to be a really interesting
product that we’re going to bring to market
and I think that’s a huge need.
And there’s a bunch of indications around
that that are in the pipeline for the non-opioid
pain alternative, so it’s pretty exciting
and it’s cool.
You have unbelievable rates of overdose happening
in this country that are unprecedented.
And we have an opportunity to—some of that
is driven by genuine need and pain.
And so some of those alternatives which are
not particularly effective (and there’s
been more studies coming out around this over
and over and over again) that I think we can
find more effective alternatives that are
safer than opioids.
And I think that’s really one of the other
focuses of United Neuroscience and something
that I’m personally passionate about, because
the Alzheimer’s and the unintentional deaths
statistics are what are driving down our longevity
for the first time in there consecutive years
since the Spanish flu.
So we should, morally, and we are, practically,
focused on addressing those biggest possible
problems.
So it’s only consistent and it’s only
right that we’re also dedicating some resource
and time and energy to addressing both the
Alzheimer’s epidemic, the Parkinson’s
epidemic, and also the non-opioid pain epidemic.
When we look at this going forward, just to
underline it I guess, these are diseases that
don’t discriminate.
I can’t articulate that enough.
These diseases don’t discriminate.
They don’t care how much money you have.
They don’t care where you live.
They don’t care what color your skin is.
And the bottom line is that our medicines
can’t discriminate either.
And so our platform technology enables us
to be accessible.
It enables us to actually go where the need
is.
And for that I’m eternally optimistic.
So that’s pretty much it.